Speaker 1: One more note about the classified
document bathroom dump that took place at Mar
a Lago. Speaker of the House Kevin
McCarthy, a Republican, was asked.
It really doesn't look good, right, for Trump
to have classified documents in his bathroom.
And McCarthy actually said bathrooms have lockable
doors and actually brought up Joe Biden. This is
you would think this were a joke. They're not
really going to do this, are they? Here is Kevin
McCarthy defending documents in the bathroom.
Speaker 2: Was that a good look for the
former president to have boxes in a bathroom?
Speaker 3: I don't know. Is
it a good picture to have
boxes in a garage that opens up
all the time, a bathroom door that.
Speaker 1: So what is he referring to? This is
the story of how Joe Biden had documents in his
garage next to his Corvette. The stupidity of this
is you can't just lift the garage door from the
outside. Like that's not how garage doors work.
But the argument that Kevin McCarthy is making
is bathrooms have lockable doors, but garages
don't. Now, it's, of course, untrue. It's also
kind of silly because bathrooms have lockable
doors from the inside. I don't. I mean, listen,
they were getting really into the weeds here,
but usually if you lock the bathroom door from
the outside, you're what we would call locked
out many of the doors with a little pin. You
can unlock it from the outside. So is that even
really secure? But we are at the level. The point
here is the following It's not about Locksmith
three. It's about Kevin McCarthy is trying to
defend the indefensible in the same way that these
Republicans have been doing it now for a while,
which is to either talk about Hillary Clinton or
in this particular case to talk about Joe Biden.
It is laughable, but it is not unexpected.
We have a cult. That is what this is. And
Kevin McCarthy defending the bathroom
dump. You got to see it to believe it.